there are plenty of movies to be excited
about coming in the back half of 2022.
of course there's a usual superhero fair
with the likes of thor love and thunder
and black adam jordan peel has another
horror treat releasing that's bound to
provide amp or social commentary in the
form of nope and we're finally getting
the long-awaited sequel to avatar with
avatar the way of water however for some
people the most anticipated movie of the
year isn't a superhero project or
something related to aliens it's about
one of the most iconic women ever to
grace hollywood marilyn monroe blonde
starring anna de armas as monroe follows
the life of the world-renowned actress
as she came from humble beginnings to
take over pop culture the film's already
making waves for its nc 17 rating a
first for netflix where will be released
and now that photos in the teaser
trailer have also dropped from the
project people on social media are
already losing their minds and offering
the greatest of praise toward the
project many believe the actress has an
oscar in her future as she's already
demonstrated how much she's embodied
marilyn monroe from the trailer alone
one twitter user wrote
the way ana de armas has the oscar in
the bag that laughs at the mirror while
a lot of people agree that it will be
tough for her to win seeing how the film
has an nc17 rating many are still
hopeful the talented actress can at
least land the nomination another
twitter user is certainly pulling for a
win stating
haven't seen blonde yet but can tell
that oscar is calling out arnold armas
name for her performance in it
then there are those who aren't
necessarily thinking of oscar prospects
all they can think about is how similar
anna de armas looks to marilyn monroe
and how that's a very good sign for the
quality of the upcoming film a lot of
people probably feel similarly to this
twitter user who wrote omg i can barely
tell the difference between anna de
armas and marilyn monroe they look so
similar this film is going to be so good
i can't wait to watch this
it's a joy to see this kind of hype
building around the project not based on
a superhero and no doubt netflix will be
pleased with the reception when blonde
debuts on september 23rd anna de armas
is said to have a very good 2022 in
addition to blondes coming out later
this year she is also set to star in
another netflix original film the grey
man it should come as no surprise that
the actress has a lot on her plate
seeing how she's one of the most
in-demand actresses working today and
her fans already have an idea of the
kind of role she should take next when
you look online you'll find a lot of
people comparing the actress's
portrayals of marilyn monroe to evelyn
hugo who is evelyn hugo you might ask
she's a protagonist of the hit 2017
novel the seven husbands of evelyn hugo
the character herself is an old
hollywood type who recounts her life
story to a journalist and the book has
already been picked up to be adapted
into a feature film courtesy of netflix
many people seem to think that armas
would be perfect for the role of evelyn
especially seeing how much the character
has in common with monroe and twitter
has become a hotbed for the fan casting
one twitter user wrote anna de armas as
marilyn monroe is literally how i
imagined evelyn hugo
of course there are those who see the
armors as monroe as a bit depressing
because it could mean the actress won't
want to play similar characters back to
back with another twitter user
mentioning the way this probably means
we won't have anna de armas as evelyn
hugo is so oddly upsetting to me no
casting announcements for the seven
husbands of evelyn hugo have been made
yet so for now fans can still dream of
what may be
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]